this tight end at the U was just granted
his 9th year of NCAA eligibility now how
is 9 years of college eligibility even
possible let's go through it 25-year-old
Kam cormi began his college football
career at Oregon in 2016 he R shirted
his freshman year played significant
minutes for the Ducks his sophomore year
before breaking his ankle which required
many grueling surgeries putting him on
the sidelines for 3 years Benny healed
so 2 weeks into the 2021 season he tore
his Achilles so a fourth year ball went
down the drain after being out for all
that time he returned to last year and
he came in hot he ended up playing all
13 games for the Ducks and put up
impressive numbers so he wanted to keep
going and with his red shirt year and Co
year in 2020 he petitioned for his ninth
year of college football eligibility and
he got it